when we're talking about nutrients all
of these discussions should be framed in
terms of bioavailability how much of
that nutrient can you actually get out
of that plant let's just think about
spinach when you're eating spinach do
you think are you eating it because
you're like i'm getting a certain
mineral out of it or a vitamin or
something i'm eating it because
i do think that there are some some some
nutrients to it but i also think that
there's fiber in it so spinach is
actually a really interesting one
because spinach is very very hot don't
don't no no no don't worry my life
you're gonna ruin my life
oxalates knowledge is power you're
welcome no it's actually really high in
oxalates most skinny stones in the world
i think 80 percent are calcium oxalate
kidney stones where do we get oxalate we
get oxalate from things like almonds
spinach rhubarb beets beet greens very
high in oxalates so chocolate also is
pretty high in oxalates jen we need to
end this interview it's over
[Music]
hi welcome to the pretty intense podcast
on the show today is dr paul saladino i
stumbled onto paul on social media
looking at you know different diets i'm
always seeking for the next health thing
and he popped up and he eats a carnivore
diet he has a podcast called the
fundamental health podcast he also has a
book called carnivore code he's a double
board certified medical doctor on this
quest to understand really like at our
root what should we as human beings be
eating and then also what are the root
causes of um illness and of disease you
have to take notes on this one there's a
or or just listen for what the good and
the bad things are to eat according to
him because unfortunately he totally
puts vegetables on blast so
this is a real deep dive into what foods
you should and shouldn't be eating and
why
let's just say
i'm going to change my diet for a while
it's always a little bit challenging
when you change your diet to adapt it to
your lifestyle but if it makes you feel
that much better or look that much
better whatever you're trying to achieve
isn't it worth it
so i'm excited to try it out for myself
fascinating fascinating episode a lot of
thought-provoking ideas when it comes to
what you put in your mouth and how you
feel um i hope you get a lot out of it
um i'll keep you all posted i'll let you
know how this diet goes for me um we're
we're just beginning so if you like this
episode please hit subscribe hit the
bell for notifications let me know in
the comments what you thought and also
as it goes on maybe chime back in and
i'll look back at the comments and see
like does this work for people or who's
doing it are you are you out there
already doing it did you find good
benefits already i'd love to know and
i'd love to read it so um enjoy the
episode i see your lifestyle obviously
and um your sun tan which is indicative
of your lifestyle
being outside and i love being outside
but did you because you live in costa
rica right so did you move there to
literally be able to live that kind of a
lifestyle of
certain kinds of food and certain kinds
of activities and
maybe even the environment around you
and getting out of cities and into
nature was that literally why you moved
there pretty much it was an accident but
when it when it happened i embraced it
uh i came here in like february of 2021
so about a year and a half ago
i was coming back from africa
and i flew through washington dc so i
was in africa with the hadza tribe which
we can talk about if you want but i flew
back through dc and i couldn't even get
to austin there was a big storm so i was
like okay i'm going to go somewhere warm
i want to surf i haven't surfed enough
recently costa rica was high on the list
so i flew down to costa rica i think i
was going to be here for eight days
eight days turned into a month the month
turned into two and now
i own a house here and i live here full
time it was just so interesting like
getting up every morning and surfing is
grounding it's sunlight it's nature
exposure it's it's lack of everything
emf and digital worlds there's some
really cool people people have
interesting stories here
and then it was like every day i got to
be in the sun which feels so good as a
human to just
you think about like the resources
that are available to us different parts
of the world if you live in new york for
instance you have access to a lot of
people
and interesting ideas and energy but
certain times of the year the sun isn't
that high
so you don't have like that sun you know
what which which pieces of the bank
account are most important and for me
having like a huge amount of sun
available every single day an ocean and
warm water
it made the huge difference and then i
found really good sources of food here
it was yeah it's totally the way to do
it
so okay you touched on you were in
africa and you said we could talk about
that why were you in africa
what what got you to africa in the first
place
well i was really curious i really like
anthropology i wish i had studied
anthropology in college
and i never did i chemistry and biology
all the way you know like super geeky
stuff
and
i uh
i've been hearing about this tribe of
people called the hadza
over and over and over and
they were this fascinating group of
people for me they were just this tribe
that were some of the last remaining
hunter-gatherers left on the planet
there's not many left probably numbering
in the thousands
of true
close to being hunter-gatherers left on
the planet these are people who don't
farm
they just hunt every day and they gather
food they don't even have dwellings that
are permanent they have thatched huts
they make and then they break them down
they have camps they move around this
area in africa called lake yasi
another group in africa is called the
ikong which is in namibia botswana and
south africa but i couldn't go to those
places because of kobe restrictions but
tanzania was open
so
i just decided now is the time i want to
go visit the hadza i've never been to
africa but i went to tanzania you fly
into
you know uh you fly into right by
kilimanjaro you go to this town that's
right by likiasi so it's like
20 hours 26 hours of flight to africa
then you have to drive four or five
hours from your flight in kilimanjaro
then you have to drive another hour and
a half every morning through the bush to
like find them in the jungle or in the
bushes
yeah so you're way out there and then
you just it's incredible like as soon as
we got to meet them they were super
welcoming
and they just let you be a part of the
tribe and we got to hunt with them we
got to hang out with them we sat by the
campfire at six in the morning and 7 30
at night we got to sing with them and
just eat with them i mean i ate
crazy stuff with them so it's just
incredible to see
like baboon brains
would you do it um i mean i'd probably
try about anything it would be it would
be a mind over matter thing it actually
was really good i've had brains i've had
brains before so i didn't think it was
going to be bad
afterwards people were all worried oh
prions but there's never been a case of
prion disease that actually jumped from
what's prion so prions are
never heard of mad cow disease yeah
this is like a semi-infectious particle
of protein so people have this long
debate our virus is alive people also
debate are prions alive prions are just
a piece of protein it's an amino acid
sequence that makes up a protein and
when it gets into your body it causes
other proteins to misfold so it causes
this chain reaction this oftentimes
aggregate reaction in the brain which
can cause protein misfolding and
neuronal damage there's a disease in
humans called crutchfield yaakov disease
which is associated with certain
genetics and certain proteins and that
is a prion disease and a variant of
crutchfield jacob is mad cow disease so
in britain a number of years ago there
was an outbreak of this mad cow disease
where by eating the neural tissue the
brain the spinal cord or even the meat
of some of these cows people could get
infected with this prion so it caused
this huge stir this probably is the type
of thing that happens in livestock
because of crowding right factory
farming and the wrong type of treatment
of animals and i think that in this
situation they were actually feeding
pieces of cows to other cows so the
reason it was spreading was because the
cows were eating other cow parts like
waste or compost from other cows
which is probably not a good idea cows
probably shouldn't eat other cows
especially if they're in isolation and
in
these cordoned off you know areas where
they're in sort of factory farms so
that's prion disease
and
people believe that hiv is a virus that
probably jumped from primates to humans
so whenever you talk about eating baboon
brains people think like hiv and prions
but i'm okay
yeah so
okay so then we're gonna back up a leap
to go why why was it that you felt like
this driving force to go to africa and
experience something more primal and
something more natural and something
that i'm imagining was different than
what you were experiencing at home was
there an impetus was there um something
that was that were you in a situation
that was totally different were you i
don't even know what your job was before
were you sitting at a desk and you're
like screw this i need to get on my
surfboard and i need to go do other
things like why did you end up wanting
to really go to africa especially at
such an interesting time um
and in life where everybody is you know
scared of everything you're like i need
to get out of here
have you ever seen the movie back to the
future yeah
did you ever want to go in the delorean
did you ever want to go on a time
machine dude i always want to go on a
time machine i am always wanting to go
at all times i want to just like
i want to experience this sort of time
as an illusion thing and jump timelines
and dimensions and
yes all the time
so this is the closest thing i've ever
done to being in a time machine
and that's i think what's interesting
about anthropology and studying groups
of people
who live differently than we do in 2022
you and i know what it's like to live in
new york city or chicago or california
or texas or costa rica in 2022
but what was it like to live in africa
or any of those places 50 000 years ago
or 75 000 years ago and this is the
closest that i thought i could get to a
time machine these people
hunter gatherers that still live on the
earth live so much differently than we
live it's the closest thing to a time
machine it's not a perfect time machine
the delorean's broken a little bit
they've been influenced by
modern humans but they actively
avoid
modernity in their life they know about
cell phones they see our cell phones we
show them pictures of rhinoceros
on the cell phone and they get all
excited and they want to go hunt it but
they don't want to leave their lifestyle
they live
the most similarly to the way that
humans lived 50 to 75 000 years ago of
anyone on the planet right now and it's
you know just miles different than we do
today so they're so much closer to the
way that humans lived 75 000 years ago
than anything else on the planet that
that was what i wanted to see where did
we come from that's the question that i
was looking to answer where do we come
from and there are many people who
believe that that hadza are the direct
descendants of homo sapiens that homo
sapien there's different you know we
don't exactly understand where homo
sapiens arose and there's a lot of
different lineages of
homo
the homogeneous and there's you know all
sorts of neanderthals and denisovans and
you know different peoples but homo
sapiens
we believe this this that our species
arose
in this region of africa this sort of um
this the olduvai gorge has footprints of
pre-hominids that we believe were the
predecessors of homo sapiens so many
people believe the hadza are direct
descendants of homo sapiens and this is
perhaps the closest thing we will ever
come to understanding where we've been
as humans so what you see there is
fascinating it's just a time machine and
that's the way they they wear animal
skins and they wear shorts that are
dirty that missionaries have given them
but they wear animal skins
for shirts and they hunt with arrows
that they fashion by hand they use bows
that they carve by hand from the trees
in their area and they we saw them shoot
birds and they you know obviously killed
a baboon with us and then they
make a fire with no lighters you know
they us they use wood and they
essentially they rub two sticks together
they have a
they have a bow drill type of
method and they they also spin the they
spin the wood in their hands and they
get a they get an ember and they use
that on tinder they make fire in two
minutes or less they smoke the animal
they burn the hair off we cut into it
and we're eating the organs and then so
it's just fascinating because one of the
questions that
is so fascinating to me as a physician
is
is there
a program written into this homo sapien
dna
that gives us an idea of the way we're
supposed to eat
you know is there a program other
animals pretty clearly have species
appropriate and species inappropriate
diets
do you have dogs i do yeah so i have
dogs too and
like i've been around other dogs and you
know dog farts are a bad thing but my
dogs don't really fart i never like
smell their farts unless somebody feeds
them something like a cookie or a hot
dog bun i was doing a reel for fourth of
july where i was throwing hot dogs in
the buns saying i wasn't a fan of like
hot dogs and a bunch of ketchup and of
course all my dogs just spill [ __ ] yeah
they're both [ __ ] they're [ __ ] the
dog just one of my dogs whose name is
rib eye runs into the jungle and just
goes he just goes crazy he eats them hot
dogs he'll he'll eat junk food if i give
it to him right so he'll eat ketchup and
hot dogs and he's eating the buns and
then he has horrible gas and he farts
all over the place and his skin doesn't
look as good so this is just a
roundabout way of saying that i think
that we see this in animals and i think
it's really fascinating but we don't
really think about this in humans like
the question is is there a species
appropriate diet for humans and that may
be as large or as small as we want to
define it like maybe a
species-appropriate diet for humans is
much bigger than what i'm imagining but
that's what i'm really trying to
understand because when i went to
medical school and residency and before
medical school i was a physician
assistant so i had lots of years of
medical training and i started in
medical school one and a half times
i've been around a lot of the medical
world for a long time like never was i
taught to ask this question
like how the heck is a human supposed to
eat it's almost like we assume we know
how we're supposed to eat but to me
that's the most fascinating question
that no one really has figured out an
answer to and then the corollary
questions are are different people
different you know we're all homo
sapiens but is is you know is danica
going to eat differently than paul or
you know is are some people going to do
better with more plants or some people
going to do better with left less plants
and then the deeper questions for me as
a physician that are super fascinating
are around how many of the chronic
illnesses that we
accept as inevitable in humans whether
it's heart disease dementias alzheimer's
parkinson's neuro degeneration arthritis
arthritis whether it's rheumatoid or
osteoarthritis thyroid hormone problems
whatever autoimmune disease or chronic
illness you want diabetes obesity how
many of these diseases that we accept is
inevitable are preventable or reversible
if we can align the diet with what our
dna program is a program is expecting
like if there is actually a user manual
written into our dna as humans
into what we are supposed to be eating
well what have you figured out
could you heal humans right yeah i mean
i agree i think this is fascinating i
ask this question all the time too and i
i test on myself all kinds of things you
know i mean probably the worst test i
did was trying to eat less animal meat
i mean i just truly felt bad for the
animals it was an ethics thing it was a
compassion it wasn't about not liking
the taste of it i mean freaking love
steak um love lamb love duck love elk
you name it like i'll eat all of them um
but i
started eating you know i would have
more fish i would have a little bit of
fish at night but pretty much all
plant-based the rest of the day and then
you're substituting and when you look at
the label of some of the [ __ ] fake
meat i mean it's terrible i'm like wait
what's worse i don't know god and then i
round about thought about well what's
the
what's the value of protein you know
just do we have to have protein do we
have to have that much protein can we
get the protein from in other ways from
plants or other things and so i went
through that but there's no doubt in my
mind
there's no doubt that i feel the best on
high fat animal animal meat no no doubt
and so i i abandoned like i'm totally
okay with it i mean do i want to see the
truck driving down the road that's full
of cows heading to a slaughterhouse
absolutely not
and i don't i feel so bad i
was watching a nascar race and there's
the winner gets a lobster and this thing
is gigantic and i'm just watching it
going oh
oh
and my mom my mom was like what is it
the lobster i'm like yeah
but i just i know that it's you know
makes me feel better so
what um like what has what tests have
you done on yourself i think you were
vegan at some point in time right i was
vegan about 15 years ago for seven
months i had 20 to 25 pounds less muscle
mass on my body so i'm like a moderately
muscled male and you can imagine me with
20 pounds less muscle it was really
skinny i couldn't get a date you know i
would like ask a girl out and she would
say
you're too skinny and that was almost
when the light bulb went off
evolutionarily my body is like you're an
idiot start eating meat like you're
never gonna procreate or even get to
practice if you don't eat some meat dude
like this girl is saying you're too
skinny so i was like okay but yeah i had
a horrible vegan phase it was really bad
gas my gi symptoms were out of control
you couldn't be in the same room with me
when i was vegan
and then you know and i had my own
autoimmune issues i've had my own
autoimmune issues throughout my life
mine are not as severe as many peoples
are but i have eczema and asthma which
is a sort of a family of conditions
known as atp
these atopic conditions so i have atopic
dermatitis which is these red itchy
bumps that will come up on my wrists and
my elbows and my knees and when i was in
medical school at times i had eczema so
bad i was doing jiu jitsu it would get
infected it would cause impetigo so
that's it's not a bad thing in general
but it can be a bad thing for a lot of
humans and people are very
self-conscious about their eczema people
can get on their face and on their body
it doesn't look good on your skin to
have eczema and asthma is a lung
condition which is fairly serious and
these are autoimmune conditions and
growing up
my dad is a doctor he's an internist my
mom is a nurse practitioner
and neither of them
were taught
to think
is our son eating something that is
causing this eczema for him as a kid i
had this i had these little itchy bumps
right i'm eating regular pasteurized
dairy i'm eating processed food
even though my family is medical family
we were eating tb dinners i was eating
seed oils i was eating processed sugars
we'd go to mcdonald's and instead of
thinking
my incredibly intelligent and super kind
father instead of thinking maybe we
should feed our son differently they
give me inhalers and creams
it doesn't this doesn't solve the
problem at all this is kind of the this
is what i've always been trying to
figure out for myself and why
i don't know i think growing up in a
medical family you get fascinated by
these questions of how humans can live
better i'm not as much obsessed about
living long i just want to live well
every single day i want the quality and
i'm not willing to sacrifice
the quality of my life experience any
day for some empty promise of longevity
especially when that empty promise of
longevity is hard to prove there's a lot
of people out there now saying if you do
this you'll live longer it's like okay
maybe in 70 years we'll find out if
that's true or not right and a lot of
the things they're saying are like eat
less meat but then you look at the
research it's not substantiated anyway
so i've been trying to understand for
myself how do i fix my eczema because
though my eczema would come and go i
knew there was an autoimmune condition
going on there's this subclinical
inflammation going on in my body i don't
want this and multiple dietary
interventions so vegan horrible gas
super skinny can't get a date then i do
paleo which is meat and vegetables and
nuts and seeds and it's okay but it
still happens and that's when i was in
medical school having pretty severe
eczema flares having impetigo having
infections of my skin from doing jujitsu
and wrestling and then i go to residency
at the university of washington and i
have a really bad eczema flare when i'm
experimenting with like medicinal
mushrooms things like reishi and chaga
cordyceps things we are told are good
for us i think triggered a massive
eczema flare for me and i kind of
kind of get really frustrated and i
think okay this is this is ridiculous
like i need to just get really simple in
my diet so that was the beginning of a
carnivore diet for me the simplest
version of this elimination diet was
just meat and organs like liver and
heart and fat and salt and i did that
for two years
and
then after i did that
i had to transition to something else
because the
i ended up with significant issues with
my electrolytes because the ketogenic
diet didn't work well for me so a
carnivore diet of just
meat and organs and fat leads to some
pretty serious ketogenic
states for a lot of humans and that led
to electrolyte problems for me
palpitations muscle cramps so as i'm
going through i'm trying to learn and
correct a carnivore diet fixed the
eczema
by cutting out a variety of foods but
then i had to kind of put some foods
back in and figure out what i could do
that was the best and that was where i
ended up so basically where i am now
like an animal-based diet
reincorporating things like fruit and
honey for carbohydrates very curious
because i feel like most people would
say that most people would think a
carnivore diet is just all meat
um and i would have guessed that too but
obviously i've seen what you eat and
there's fruit and there's honey and then
there's uh dairy there's raw you know
there's kefir and things like that and
lots of butter so i mean i think that
could have been considered carnivore but
um but yeah what um how long have you
been at this diet now because one of the
other things i would say is that in the
quest of trying to figure it out like
there are people that go vegan and they
feel great for a period of time and then
all of a sudden it just catches up with
them so you know i always think of
myself as an ongoing process and i'm
sure that whatever i'm doing right now
i'll think to myself in 10 years i can't
believe i was eating that you know
because i can look back 10 years from 10
years ago from today and be like i can't
believe i was eating that and i was
doing the best i could so how long have
you been eating sort of adaptive
carnivore or what would you give it a
different title based on the fact i call
it animal-based animal-based
yeah and it's that's been about two to
three years now and i get blood work
every six months to a year i just
released on my podcast which is called
fundamental health
a review of my july 2022 blood work
because everybody thinks i'm going to
die
they thought i was going to die since i
started carnivores you don't look like
you're going to die so
but people think like oh you're going to
get heart disease right you're going to
get these silent killers you surely have
heart disease or something and then you
show them a picture of your arteries and
they're all clear and or you show them a
coronary artery calcium scan which is a
zero with no calcium in my arteries and
you say and look i'm totally insulin
sensitive i don't think i have coronary
artery disease and they still don't
believe you it's it's it's an
interesting ongoing conversation such
kind of songs around like exclusions of
food and things that we were
fundamentally taught are important you
know i mean just you know growing up
eating cheerios you know
[Music]
yes i think that
so i run out write a kid's book
and i want to write
i want to write a kids book
for parents
that talks about
the basic plot is like your kids don't
need to eat vegetables and i want to do
like whether it's like a cave kid or
some kind of you know set in neanderthal
times or some you know like 50 000 years
ago through like the tribe in africa
yes you know like the kids in africa
don't eat vegetables and i want to
circle back to the hots and tell you
about what they eat and what they
prioritize but i want to write a kids
book because i think that
you know i don't have kids but my sister
has a two-year-old and a four-year-old
and
you know not a pediatrician but i've
done enough medical training to know
that kids don't need to eat vegetables
but we've all been told this is deeply
ingrained into every psyche that my mom
and my grandma would say eat your
vegetables well vegetables are better
than snickers bars but i'm not convinced
that vegetables are great for humans and
that is one of the more controversial
statements that i make with my work it's
not the one that i really want people to
get so wrapped around the axle axolon
i'd rather they
start doing their own questioning about
their diet i just want people to think
about diet i want people to cut out
processed sugar and seed oils which we
can talk about too and if they really
want to go down the rabbit hole
and follow the stuff i'm working on then
you can worry about vegetables and
whether you include them in your diet or
not
but i just i want to write this kid's
book that says like you know charlie the
cave kid doesn't like vegetables and
it's actually good for him because how
much consternation at dinner tables i
mean i don't you probably have nieces or
nephews or people in your life you see
like how much
stress for parents and kids could be
avoided if you don't force your kids to
eat pea soup and broccoli and spinach
right like if you don't eat your
vegetables i remember vomiting in my pea
soup as a child like i am scarred
my parents forced me to eat pea soup and
i just it's a lot of trauma around
vegetables and children
right so what if and a lot of lying and
lying with parents when they put it in
something and blend it into a smoothie
and then kids like i was thinking kids
like hiding it in their milk or like
hiding it under the plate or like
knocking it off the table like this is
every kid knows this if i move the peas
around on my plate
i don't it looks like i've eaten enough
of them if i move the vegetables if i
smash the broccoli then i've eaten
enough of it so why do kids do this well
i think one really compelling
possibility is that
as children we don't have these
programming and we just know that like
that's bitter and i don't want to eat a
bitter thing i'm not really programmed
as a child to eat broccoli or kale or
spinach
you can look at these studies there were
studies done in the 1930s and 1940s
where they give children a selection of
foods meat and fruit and vegetables and
milk and butter and cheese and the kids
essentially go for meat and they go for
fruit and they go for dairy most of the
time the majority of the foods they're
going to select are fruit and meat and
if you can get your kids to eat organs
you're like the kid's going to be
superhero and that's tricky for both
adults
and kids but if we just didn't have to
force children to eat vegetables and we
just said hey you can eat some
strawberries and have some grass-fed
hamburger and you know maybe you have a
little bit of
a little bit of cucumber or something
there for the kid but just meat and
fruit is a great diet for kids they're
going to be happier their parents are
going to be happier anyway it's kind of
this idea of like vegetables are they
really what we want to eat as humans
do you know how many times i've thought
about you while i eat my vegetables
because i truly love vegetables that's
the problem i really love vegetables and
also then i and i want to talk about
this too but then i think about like
caloric density too and i think about
you know i think about how much how many
grams of protein should i really be
having at once and i think about just
total caloric load as well and
vegetables are not calorically dense so
you know i think about all those things
but i really just enjoy vegetables so as
i'm putting like spinach in with my
bison that i saute it you know put in
the pan in the morning and then i'm like
um and then you know i'm putting like
micro greens on it and then at lunch i'm
having a salad of like arugula and
radicchio and fennel and some onion and
you know some chicken and then i'm like
jeez am i dying from the chicken because
it's like just like a bird and like not
the most intelligent animal and not has
really no fat in it
and i'm like oh i don't know and then
avocado i'm like but is this the fruit
maybe this is okay and i'm like just
like i think to myself how am i killing
myself and i was like i'm going to be
able to ask you
i i i find
i find it amusing that i'm like haunting
you a little bit that there's like a
little bit like totally haunting me but
i tell you what
as i drank my um my
my kefir this morning i thought i was
channeling you though yeah there's like
a little carnivore md angel
carnivorously devil on your shoulders
like yes good job or that's [ __ ]
danica why are you eating totally i'm
like the salad is such [ __ ] i know
it it's going over my shoulder right now
it's just rotated over your shoulder a
couple of things i say to people who
say but i love vegetables the first
thing i say is do you like vegetables
plain like and some people say yes but i
think a lot of people like vegetables
because they're in a sauce or because
you're putting butter or salt or a salad
dressing which may or may not actually
have seed oils right so i mean when
somebody invented salad dressing it was
brilliant if you go to the grocery store
and i do this all the time you know this
from my social media and i just call
[ __ ] on everything but a lot of the
salad dressings have processed sugar and
seed oils so of course you like
you know radicchio or arugula when it
has
you know a sweet oily salad dressing on
it because that is tapping into
evolutionary programming we are still i
think that is 20 22 humans we like to
believe that we're like super smart but
we are really programmed as the same as
the hadza we're still 75 50 25 000 year
old programming in our brains because
there hasn't really been clear selective
pressure to change us as humans which
means that
your body isn't used to the candy bar
when your body sees sweet it thinks it's
fruit and that's why these processed
food manufacturers can really take
advantage of this and they can say aha
your body is programmed to like sweet
because if you are here in the jungle
with me like the only thing that you're
going to get in the jungle that's sweet
is fruit there's no snickers bars
growing on trees or honey so of course
if you eat something sweet in nature
your body's going to say yes eat more of
that
i like that that's good for me and we
can talk about the research showing that
the fruit is beneficial for humans and
even that honey is really beneficial for
humans and then we also have programming
that tells us
fat is good eat fat like fat is survival
fat is fertility for both women and men
fat is thriving getting a fatty animal
was probably the most celebrated thing
in our life you know in a week and a
month and a year the hazza celebrate a
successful hunt more than anything else
and we'll talk about that so there are
all of these programs in us you're
programmed to like fat
and sweet and salty things yeah so what
are you know what are junk food like
whether you're talking about lace potato
chips or doritos or takis or snickers
candy bars they're sweet or salty or
fatty and often they combine all of them
so it's like
processed food manufacturers are really
smart and perhaps they deserve props for
that but i think they're leveraging that
that
deep knowledge of human physiology and
what we crave against us so
we're trying to fight our programming
but we need to understand that there are
good things that we've always
evolutionarily had that will fulfill
those needs and those are things like
honey and butter and fatty meat so when
people say i like vegetables i say okay
does your does your vegetable have
butter on it does it have a sauce does
it have something sweet on it because
that's going to confuse your body you
might say oh somebody might say oh my
kid loves broccoli and i said well did
you put cheese on it and they say yeah
well okay of course like i like broccoli
with cheese on it too i just understand
that my body wants the cheese
and if i have to eat broccoli to get the
cheese fine but your body wants the
cheese your body wants the dairy
every once in a while i talk to someone
who says no i really just like
vegetables and i say okay
fair enough
do you eat organs
because i think that there are nutrients
in vegetables
and a lot of us
grew up eating meat but very few of us
grew up eating liver or heart or
other organs that are more exotic like
kidney and so people will say to me i
crave vegetables and i say okay your
body can only crave what it knows this
is just my hypothesis like it's only
going to crave what it knows and so if
you are if you're really not eating a
lot of meat but you're iron deficient
you might crave some spinach because
your body's trying to get some of that
you know inorganic iron
the heme iron in meat is going to be
much better for somebody with an iron
deficiency but if you're not eating a
lot of meat
why is your body going to crave that
because you don't actually it's not
actually in your wheelhouse right
so i think that sometimes people crave
vegetables because
they don't have a full pallet of foods
for their body to kind of crave and
choose from you know what i mean like
all the characters on the video game
aren't there because we didn't grow up
eating organs but when i'm with the
hadza the first thing we do is eat the
liver
and the heart
and the kidneys and i mean everything
all the organs come out and the kids eat
it and then women eat it and then we're
breaking open the bones for bone marrow
later so it's like you need to think
about all the characters in the video
game and
this is where people get a little
squeamish because they think i'm never
eating organs right and there's all
kinds of solutions for that which we can
talk about but
those are my that's my long-winded
answer for why you might like vegetables
so do you think so are you saying that
the from a nutrient perspective that the
organ meat can replace vegetables
absolutely so if you're talking about
vitamins and minerals i mean if you're
eating fruit for vitamin c there's
nothing in vegetables that you can't get
from eating meat and organs and if you
look at it whether you i don't
doesn't matter if you want to look at
vitamin a or choline or choose your
nutrient you know zinc or magnesium or
whatever it's more bioavailable it's
usually absolutely more
present in animal foods than it is in
plant foods we're not really good at
absorbing nutrients from plant foods
this is something i'll say
and this is a really important point
we're often told if you go on like the
internet if you go to the interwebs and
you and you do a google and you do this
search and you say okay
what foods are high in iron i guarantee
you plant foods are going to be at the
top of that list and you do a search
what foods are high in zinc oh plant
foods are going to be at the top of the
list but what they're not telling you in
those lists is that that iron and that
zinc
those minerals are not bioavailable in
plant foods you know there's spin
studies with zinc specifically and they
give people oysters you know oysters are
a really good source of zinc so is liver
so is muscle meat from animals so you
can give someone an oyster and you can
see their blood level of zinc rise but
this is a great study this wouldn't be
repeated today because i don't know who
would fund it but then you give someone
that oyster with black beans
and that zinc level in the blood is just
is cut in half it only rises about half
and then you give them a tortilla so you
give them wheat with the oyster and
there is no rise in the zinc level at
all in their body
so there are these compounds
in
nuts and seeds and beans so wheat is
grain right it's a seed they're called
phytic acid and oxalates and they kind
of chelate they bite onto minerals and
they make these minerals very poorly
bioavailable so anyone who thinks that
they're going to get zinc from pumpkin
seeds is just being misled you're not
going to get sick from pumpkin seeds
yeah you're not a [ __ ] selenium from
brazil nuts
it's not very bioavailable right there's
enough selenium and brazil nuts that you
might get some
that selenium is a different type of
selenium than the selenium found in meat
this is selenium methionine versus
selenocysteine and the meat selenium
appears to be more bioavailable so i
think meat is a better source of
selenium than
brazil nuts but this is a perfect
example like how bioavailable is the
selenium in a brazil nut how much of it
is chelated by the phytic acid how much
of it is
chelated by the oxalates we know that in
terms of zinc and iron you're not
getting it you're not getting it from
almonds people say oh magnesium i love
thinking about magnesium people say okay
i'm going to get magnesium from almonds
you're not getting any magnesium from
your almonds because they're so full of
oxalates and phytic acid you're not
absorbing that magnesium much at all so
what are oxalates in phytic acid then so
phytic acid is a large molecule uh we
could pull up like a wikipedia picture
just imagine like a large molecule a
carbon containing structure a large
molecule that chelates meaning it bites
onto a mineral plants use phytic acid to
store minerals they need to store the
minerals like phosphorus and calcium and
manganese and magnesium because they use
those to germinate once the seed
actually germinates like a brazil nut is
a seed it doesn't have selenium in it
for you it has selenium in it for the
actual plant when it wants to grow into
a brazil plant right so the way that it
holds onto that mineral is with a
compound called phytic acid which
chelates those minerals
oxalate is another compound it's a
dicarboxylic acid so it's a much smaller
two carbon molecule and it but it also
can prevent the absorption of these
molecules by binding to them and pulling
them out of your gut so when we're
talking about nutrients
all of these discussions should be
framed in terms of bioavailability
how much of that nutrient can you
actually get out of that plant
because let's just think about spinach
like when you're eating spinach do you
think are you eating it because you're
like i'm getting a certain mineral out
of it or a vitamin or something
i'm eating it because
i do think that there are some some some
nutrients to it but i also think that
there's fiber in it as well and so just
for
regularity and keeping fiber up i think
well i might as well add a whole bunch
of spinach it disappears it's
calorically
pretty minimal
you can put big handfuls in the pan and
cook it down and it's like nothing so
spinach is actually a really interesting
one because spinach is very very hot
don't don't no no no don't worry my life
you're gonna ruin my life
oxalates knowledge is power you're
welcome i know that's exactly why i'm
talking to you
no it's actually really high in oxalates
and if you go to any so a mainstream
kidney doctor which we call a
nephrologist if you have kidney stones
uh most kidney stones in the world i
think 80 percent are calcium oxalate
kidney stones where do we get oxalate we
get oxalate from things like almonds
spinach rhubarb beets beet greens very
high in oxalates and these oxalates can
accumulate in humans and we don't really
fully understand this
we haven't really studied it because who
is funding this so we know pretty
clearly even i'm going to ruin your life
i'm just ruining your life danny i'm
sorry you know hey look my people all
know like they're all like what are you
eating these days i mean this can be
like
you know sweet hayley who's been with me
for 14 years she's like so what what are
you eating these days because i will
evolve my diet based on more information
so
okay let me have it
so chocolate also is pretty high in
oxalates as is turmeric and turmeric uh
jen we need to end this interview it's
over i'm talking about
like
so we know there's been studies where
they give people now this is a lot of
chocolate it's like two to four ounces
of chocolate this is like valentine's
day amounts of chocolates but you can
see that in their urine the oxalic acid
goes up to levels that are pathological
you get the amount of oxalate in your
urine is the same as somebody with like
a genetic condition that causes oxalate
dumping and massive urinary stones and
the kidneys staghorn calculi
so if you eat that's with two to four
ounces of chocolate i'm just saying like
chocolate has a lot of oxalates and you
can push the amount of oxalic acid in
your kidneys very high and you can
excrete it but maybe it forms a stone or
maybe it deposits somewhere in your body
so there's been autopsy studies also of
human thyroids there's no role for
oxalic acid and human thyroids when they
look at autopsies the majority of human
thyroids have oxalate deposits in them
and so the question is like okay what is
oxalic acid doing in the thyroid is it
potentially harmful and then we see
lower levels of oxalate in people whose
thyroids are affected by autoimmune
thyroid conditions like hashimoto's
thyroiditis so you think okay this is
just all hypothesis but this is the type
of thing that i want my work to make
western medicine ask these questions is
it possible that some autoimmunity at
the level of the thyroid is triggered by
a reaction against oxalate being
deposited in the thyroid there's no real
critical role for oxalate in the human
body it's a waste product when you break
down certain amino acids you excrete a
small amount of oxalic acid oxalate but
when you dump spinach into your bison
you're just pushing that oxalate up and
up and up and you're just making more
and more oxalates to be deposited
everywhere joints thyroid kidneys i mean
this is probably the worst one there's a
whole group of people out there who have
vulvar pain
that resolves when they stop eating
oxalates it's called vulvodynia they
can't sit like women can't sit
because it hurts so badly
to sit in the vulva like
from
and it appears to be related to oxalate
deposition
in the in the in the nether regions in
the most precious part you know in the
most tender regions
so this is just one of these type of
things that says like okay
is spinach really good for you let's ask
the question and try and understand how
you know danica and all your listeners
thrive the best moving forward there's
no nutrients in spinach that you can't
get from eating meat and organs and then
if you want fiber i'm gonna send you
some mangoes or papaya from costa rica
or i'm sure in jewelry or wherever you
are you can find bananas or other fruit
there's plenty of fiber i mean fiber is
a whole separate discussion which we
don't have to get into unless you really
want to but because i'm animal based now
and i'm eating fruit i think that
there's a lot of ways people can get
fiber from fruit
you don't necessarily need more fiber
from vegetables and
i mean i think both women and men will
appreciate this i think that
most people that i speak to when they
cut the vegetables out of their diet or
decrease them they have less gas they
fart less they have less bloating their
gi systems get better which is just
easier to be a human when you can be
around people and not have to like sneak
over the corner to like you know fart or
something
i can't say that's a huge problem but i
mean i'm definitely interested in the
oxalate side of things and the part
where it makes the
nutrients less bioavailable and or or is
actually counterproductive
um so okay does this apply basically to
all vegetables i mean i know you know
there's some obviously some doctors that
have made lectins pretty um
pretty a pretty big conversation piece
when it comes to health i think gundry's
kind of led the way on that um so i have
done
after interviewing him i i definitely
steer clear of more of those but i do
get confused then when it comes to okay
what about broccoli what about
cauliflower what about zucc and while
the zucchini is a lectin
but you know some of those other ones is
it oxalates being the main
thing that is dangerous in some of those
other vegetables that make them
either uh
make them you know counterproductive in
the body oxalates are just one of the
problems there's like
there's many
issues so we can talk about
the brassica family which is kale
cauliflower broccoli
brussels sprouts
um all right sprouts too
yeah they're all in this this brassica
family so we can talk about that that's
a really interesting conversation yeah
so let's just define vegetables people
understand vegetable versus fruit so
vegetable is and this is actually you
can put on your like delorean 75 000
years ago hat a vegetable is any part of
a plant that's not a fruit
so if you think like a plant and you
know and you're rooted in the ground as
a plant you have roots and you have a
stem and sometimes the stem is woody and
you have leaves and then you make seeds
and the seeds are like your babies
you're going to encase your dna and the
seed all the information to make a new
plant somewhere else it's either going
to get dispersed by wind or it's going
to be in a sweet fruit which is going to
drop to the ground and get eaten and
hopefully the seed gets pooped out
somewhere else or you know the birds
come and they disperse your seeds
because they want to eat the fruit so
anything that's not a fruit is a
vegetable
technically so you're thinking about
vegetables are things like seeds so
grains nuts seeds and beans are all
vegetables
leaves are vegetables so spinach kale
chard
stems are vegetables things like celery
or what are some other stems sometimes
like asparagus is kind of like a stem
and then roots are also vegetables
this is just the differentiation and if
you think like a plant does a plant want
any part of its body
other than a fruit to be eaten
the answer is pretty clearly no like if
animals go around eating plant leaves
and bark and stems and roots they're
killing the plants which makes it less
likely for the plant to reproduce so
like the reason you don't see animals or
insects
just running around eating all of the
plants in front of you whether it's in
central park or wherever you are is
because those plants put defense
chemicals in their leaves in their bark
in their roots and in their seeds
especially that's part of the discussion
around lectins is these carbohydrate
binding proteins that are mostly present
in seeds
things like you know
beans our seeds right those are a big
source of lectins a lot of nuts are
problematic lectin containing foods for
humans so
there are lots of defense chemicals in
seeds that go even beyond the lectins
there's oxalates there's phytic acid
that we talked about but there are other
defense chemicals in leaves so in the
case of kale cauliflowers chard
all of these brassica vegetables you
have a whole family of compounds with
this complex name
isothiocyanate
and yes in the name it sort of has like
a cyanide type of thing
and they are related in some ways to
that compound they don't work exactly
the same but there's pretty good
evidence
that certain that amounts of brussels
sprouts and certain types of kale that
people eat contain enough of these
isothiocyanates like one specifically is
called goitrin to inhibit iodine
absorption at the level of the thyroid
and create potential for hypothyroidism
which is also called goiter so maybe
you've seen pictures of people
in africa or central america with a
really big thick necks have you seen
that like the real yeah that's a goiter
that's a goiter and it's from
hypothyroidism
because these people are eating
so many of the foods that have these
goitrogenic compounds
things like cassava you know is a common
root eaten in central america and
they're not eating enough foods with
iodine things like fish or meat and
organs of animals so if you're not
eating enough animal foods and you're
eating a lot of plant foods with these
defense chemicals that attack your
thyroid and prevent iodine absorption
you become iodine deficient and you get
this pathological goiter this huge thick
neck wow and these people are forced to
do this because of poverty and they
can't hunt and their hunting grounds
have been destroyed because they're no
longer living as hunter-gatherers so
this is the concern and again this is
what my work is about is asking
questions getting people to really think
like is my thyroid healthy like
do i check my thyroid do i check more
than just a tsh like am i having
autoimmune thyroid issues but i'm still
eating broccoli um is it possible i'm
eating too many oxalates so the thyroid
is i have thyroid issues so i'm really
listening right now i mean i don't know
how many i have a lot of thing i mean i
had my i had breast implants removed i
think that caused a lot of problems um
but there's always it's it's the
as you well know the body is quite the
jigsaw puzzle and like it all everything
connects in some kind of way so
so i'm really listening in and also i
think thyroid especially for women is
such a thing i think there's it's a very
very common issue so what are some of
the key things that have goidet go
what's the
well goitrogenic substance
substances
what are some of the things is are you
just kind of covering all vegetables as
being a goitrogenic substance not all
vegetables mostly the brassicas so the
things in the mustard family
kale cauliflower broccoli brussels
sprouts collard greens okay that whole
family is isothiocyanate
mom throw the sprouts away okay yeah
right
so that's like that's the problem and
people like brussels they say like i
love brussels sprouts and i say okay you
love brussels sprouts because you're
cooking them with bacon or you're
putting butter on them or something
right like these foods don't really
taste that good by themselves and this
isn't my i'm not doing this to like
limit people's dietary enjoyment and and
limit the amount of foods they can eat
i'm putting it out there for people who
are suffering who aren't finding answers
in other ways there's this kind of this
message that i've gone back to a few
times in my social media recently
because i want people to understand this
like if people are listening to this and
you are thriving you know you're you're
on point you're just kicking ass you've
got good body composition and energy and
sleep and libido and mental clarity then
don't change a thing you know i'm i
don't really i don't want to be dogmatic
about this but i want people to
understand that asking questions is the
beginning
of healing we have to ask these
questions to be curious sure and the
work i do is for people who are
continuing to suffer and they feel like
they're doing all the right things
they're eating more salads and less red
meat and they're and they're just
they're getting worse they're getting
more bloated and their autoimmune
conditions getting worse and their
eczema continues
and i've been there so that's that's why
i do biologically we're all quite
different and and i'm i'm right now
getting a big extensive cool dna test
done that's going to show pathways for
everything and you know so some people
methylate well some people can detoxify
some people some people's bodies are
just operate at a at a higher level when
it comes to
flushing of of things that come into the
body that are not ideal and some don't
and i'm guessing i'm probably a don't so
you know that's probably why i had more
complications from implants that's
probably why detoxing is something i
really am focused on right now and
lymphatic drainage and all those
different things because but but i also
could be on top of all the things that
all that i could be putting things in my
body that are really like
slowing this process down
there are many compounds in plants that
inhibit detoxification systems in the
liver
yeah so
i can so it'd be great to not have to
put a castor oil pack on me that would
be like fantastic so yeah one over my
liver
no no you don't have to do that
do you use
do you use black pepper
yeah black pepper is a seed right black
pepper is like a pepper seed so there's
a compound in pepper called piperine
and piperine inhibits
a big enzyme in the liver involved in
phase 2 detoxification the enzyme is
called udp glucuronasal transferase and
the reason that's important is because
that enzyme adds a glucuronide moiety to
toxins that your body is trying to get
rid of a lot of people think the liver
is a filter
but the liver is like a an enzymatic
powerhouse that exports
toxins from the body it doesn't store
the toxins like a sieve catching
spaghetti
right it tags toxins for excretion from
the body with glutathione with
glucuronide
with other compounds in phase two in
phase one it transforms compounds to
make them more water soluble or prepare
them for phase two so the liver
transforms waste products and toxins
that you are eating
for excretion in your urine and your
poop
and there are a lot of plant compounds
that inhibit the liver's ability to do
that
so udp
glucuronosyltransferase is this one
enzyme pepper inhibits that enzyme so
one of the reasons that do you ever take
turmeric supplements i mean i put
turmeric i'm like i hadn't okay i was
told i my blood test
chicken eggs are bad so i have duck eggs
and i put like
because black pepper activates turmeric
so you put salt pepper turmeric do you
know why black pepper activates turmeric
i don't know
because the active ingredient in
turmeric is curcumin and your body
actively excretes curcumin because it's
not actually good for humans
it's seen as a toxin by the liver
and this is not this is not opinion this
is medical science right so like
not everyone agrees with me but there's
this is i'm not talking opinion this is
there's papers that show this like
curcumin is clearly
not absorbed much by the liver whatever
is absorbed uh excuse me it's not
absorbed much by the gut whatever is
absorbed almost all of it is immediately
detoxified and excreted by your body
it's all excreted and the way it's
excreted is by glucuronidation primarily
so black pepper inhibits your body's
detoxification of curcumin and turmeric
therefore your curcumin levels in the
body go up i know people's brains just
go like what this is crazy this guy is
crazy
oh no this is this is
literally how
this is i always joke i'm like there's
them there's flax seed and then chia
seeds new flax seed and there'll be some
no chia seed and like there's always
going to be the next thing well this is
you know i think you know food is this
frontier that will kind of never end
because we're constantly discovering the
body and understanding more and we're
also having more emergent ingredients
come from all over the world as we're
able to get them and have contact and
um so i i think that no this is
this is exactly the conversation that
needs to be had so that people can start
testing for themselves what works and
also start looking into that looking
into it themselves as well and you know
this is a passion of yours so you're
just kind of leading the way on this and
and i'm listening i'm just kind of i
think i'm um
empathizing and mimicking perhaps what
other people are thinking out there as
they listen to it like i'm literally
collect i'm the collective for you right
now and i'm sure that you see it but you
know you just i'm just saying that this
is how we're feeling is like really oh
you know and it's part of it is like
okay my diet will need to change but
also it's a little bit of like you know
obviously
i'm wrong and you know it's okay to be
wrong but some people don't like being
wrong you know well i think it's not so
much being wrong it's just there are
other
narratives
out there people live differently there
are other stories you know i think that
as humans i want to come back to
curcumin and turmeric in one moment we
learned this a lot during the pandemic
we don't like it when
our narrative is challenged we sort of
want to understand that we are with a
group of people who confirms what we
believe and we have steady
stability in our worldview and our
paradigm we want to know that we get up
and the sun rises east and sets in the
west we want to know that the tree over
there has fruit this time of year we
want to know that animals are there this
time of year we want stability and so in
our world view when our when our literal
conceptualization of what is good and
bad for humans is challenged it's
stressful for us that's a good thing to
have happen because it means we're
growing and we question
you know like i don't want people
to trust me i want them to be curious
about what i'm saying and to examine all
of it and to try and debunk it and to
find out from them i want people to
think for themselves but i want them to
become curious with this and ask these
questions for themselves that's what we
are not taught in medical school it's
how to think and how to question and
it's just it's what i want to try and
make change within medicine so i don't
want people to trust me well you don't
like seeds but you're doing you're doing
you're planting them and then i'm trying
right that's a great thing i love i love
that that's what i hope to do with this
show is plant seeds and i do it
selfishly for myself but i like to pass
along the information so
yeah so let's go back to curcumin
specifically to turmeric so turmeric is
a root right it's a plant root so right
from the outset
if you
understand the paradigm that i'm
expressing like that root doesn't want
to get eaten okay so there might be
defense chemicals in that root or maybe
there's not
but why do we take turmeric we're told
that turmeric contains curcumin a
compound that is anti-inflammatory
but
why do we do that that doesn't make any
sense to me
do you take ibuprofen every day do you
take aspirin every day
do you take other compounds that are
anti-inflammatory every day your body
has a delicate system those are kind of
rhetorical questions but if you do take
those things we can talk about it but
your body has this delicate system of
prostaglandin formation and leukotriene
formation your body heals
through inflammation when you get a cut
or a broken bone or a torn ligament you
need inflammation to heal that we are
just now beginning to learn that when
you get a broken bone if you take a
bunch of ibuprofen advil you're going to
slow the healing when i was a runner so
yeah i used to be a distance runner
and whenever i would get injured i would
always say take ibuprofen i said i don't
want to take that stuff i don't believe
in that this is how my body heals and
this has been proven now in orthopedic
medicine that interrupting the
inflammatory cascade as part of a
healing process
delays the healing and prevents the
formation
of certain fatty acids that resolve the
inflammation
so this gets a little technical but what
we know is that if you have inflammation
in your body presumably from a cut or a
broken bone and you take something like
advil you are going to prevent the
formation of the compounds that
eventually resolve the inflammation it's
like your body brings in a cleanup crew
and then
the trucks that pull the cleanup crew
out of there they get broken
because and then the cleanup crew gets
stuck and they just keep cleaning and
you just keep this inflammation and like
like you're bringing crew into your
house to repaint i'm searching for
metaphors here but then the trucks that
remove the crew
are broken so you they just keep
painting and it's the same thing for
icing too does that is that enough yeah
icing doesn't really work yeah
so you want inflammation
to heal and so
when people have inflammation in their
thyroid or in their joints and
autoimmune disease that is your body
signaling to you
something is out of balance
curcumin doesn't fix the cause of that
inflammation but it can damp it down i'm
not saying that there are no plant
compounds that have pharmacologic effect
in the human body we use plants for
chemotherapy we use plants for all sorts
of pharmaceuticals but we must not
ignore the side effects of those plant
molecules and we have to understand that
using a plant
to treat the symptoms that doesn't
address the root cause is the same thing
as using a drug that's given to you by
your doctor that most people don't want
to do anymore because you don't want to
give just take a drug to get rid of the
symptoms that doesn't make sense
you know
it doesn't make sense in terms of
intuition but we're doing the same thing
with a lot of these plant compounds
they've just been sold to us as the new
sexy thing like oh there's a new celery
juice or the new curcumin turmeric it's
a multi-billion dollar industry that
makes no sense it doesn't it's just like
why would you want to get rid of
inflammation in your body you have to
treat the cause of the inflammation that
inflammation isn't just there because
you're a human existing
that inflammation is there because
something in your body is out of balance
you're both tamping down your body's
signal and you're putting a compound in
your body that has other negative
effects we haven't even talked about the
negative effects of curcumin
and then you're taking and i'm just
illustrating what's happening with you
i'm not accusing you
then you take pepper which increases
the plant compound in your body and then
all the negative effects are magnified
from the curcumin so there's lots of
great papers on this i mean there's a
paper called the dark side of curcumin
you can look up a paper called the
medicinal chemistry of curcumin and they
enumerate multiple issues with this
molecule so i just wanted to talk about
curcumin in detail because it helps
illustrate this broad paradigm
that we don't really want to be using
plant chemicals to treat symptoms
we want to be addressing the root cause
and i think that a lot of times the root
cause is in what we're eating and
sometimes the plant chemicals can
actually be the root cause themselves
sometimes well that's what i was
wondering is that the actual
inflammation is the inflammation coming
from the
makeup of the plant the defense
chemicals the
the nutrients the i don't know non
certain nutrients that are
counterproductive in the body so it
sounds like that's cute it's possible so
lectins are a good example here
if you look at the way that these
lectins work from like red kidney beans
or tomatoes they open the gap junctions
in the gut right so in your intestines
you have these epithelial cells that are
tied together with little pieces of
protein called you know like
zonulin is a protein in there and then
clottins and occludens they're zippered
together
and these lectins appear to to cause
those gap junctions to open uh gluten is
the canonical example of a lectin that
opens gap junctions because the molecule
of gluten and a fragment of gluten
called gliadin looks like a bacteria
it's our body has this evolutionary
program to open the gap junctions in our
gut to allow the immune cells to move
into the gut to fight infections if you
i hope this has never happened to you
but if you eat chicken or um a salad
that's contaminated with the bacteria
then you get food poisoning right
sometimes it happens with rice you know
at a at a restaurant or it happens with
a salad or it can happen with water in
another country or it can happen with
chicken and salmonella or eggs but then
your body your body is opening these gap
junctions you're getting inflammation in
your gut your body is fighting off
camphor bacteria salmonella whatever is
in your gut e coli but sometimes
fragments of lectins or proteins look
like bacteria and they appear to either
indirectly or directly open these gap
junctions so yes i think it's possible
that many plant compounds could be
causing inflammation in the human body
by opening gap junctions in the gut and
then we also have to just pause for a
moment and say what is inflammation i
think we throw that word around a lot
but no one really understands what it is
it's just the activation of the immune
system so if the immune system is
activated you have inflammation it's
essentially like all the cells in your
body that are immune cells you have t
cells and b cells and natural killer
cells just you know trillions of cells
that are immune cells and they all
communicate with these molecules called
cytokines it's like they can all sort of
send these molecules into the air or
into the fluid and they communicate and
when that molecular signal when that
milieu when those communications between
the immune cells says danger there's
certain interleukins there's certain
cytokines released that's inflammation
it's when
um i don't know it's almost like being
at a baseball game you know and everyone
is super excited about something it's
like the whole crowd just gets this
collective energy the same thing happens
in the immune system but it's a
collective energy that's that's like
there's something bad out there we need
to go kill it that's inflammation so
where does that come from well that
signal can start in the gut
if you damage the gut and there are lots
of things that can damage the gut maybe
gluten for some people i think for a lot
of people toxins heavy metals glyphosate
might do it this pesticide but i think
that we need to be very honest with
ourselves and ask are there other
compounds in plants
like lectins and things like this in
beans and seeds or other compounds and
plants even beyond lectins that could
also be inciting inflammation in the gut
and causing systemic inflammation
um okay
to check the boxes so your liver do you
take capsules or do you eat it raw
i do both
so you can do whatever you can't tell me
that like because you're like oh
broccoli doesn't taste good asparagus
doesn't you know you want the stuff on
it and it's like yeah same thing with
liver okay you can't tell me that
actually tastes good
this is interesting so
i i guess that's a fair point um
i think that if you feed a child
broccoli at the age of one year old
they're gonna hate it but you can feed a
child liver and a lot of them will eat
it
so there's like this programming we have
as kids right most of us don't like
liver because we didn't have it as
children and so it's more irony
i don't mind the taste of liver now it's
a little sweet i it's pretty good
actually um and i think you grow to like
any liver taste once no i eat it raw so
and you cook it and still get the
benefits though because raw seems much
more scary than cooked liver like i know
it's totally unethical probably how it's
all harvested but i mean i love foie
gras which is just liver all right yeah
fogua is not super ethical but there are
you can get regeneratively raised like
grass-fed grass-finished animals and
liver from that so cooking liver there
are some b vitamins in liver that are
that are fragile and will be denatured
when you cook them you'll still get a
lot of benefits from liver i think
choline
is fairly heat stabilized vitamin a
there are vitamins and minerals in liver
that are heat stabilized
stable but there's some that are heat
labile which are going to be denatured
by the cooking process which is why
you know maybe like that's why i think
something like a desiccated organ so
full disclosure i have this company
hardened soil we make these desiccated
organ pills one of the cool things about
freeze drying in oregon is you're
essentially dehydrating the organ that's
33 degrees fahrenheit so you're at a
freezing temperature you're taking the
water out of an organ so the idea is you
can get an organ that you don't have to
taste but it still has as many nutrients
as possible because you're gently sort
of making like freeze-dried organs so
raw organs always have a risk raw food
whether it's a vegetable or an animal
has a risk of contamination if your
source is good and especially if you
pre-freeze the liver it's
reasonably safe to eat raw liver
but if you don't want to do that you
could cook it you could sear the outside
maybe the inside is still a little pink
right exactly
yeah or like chopping it up and putting
it in things like i buy a i buy a ground
ground beef that has um organ meat in it
and it's in it yeah yeah perfect i mean
it kind of you know so it changes the
texture a little bit but it's it's still
like i'm just i eat it every week
because i'm
been watching too many videos of yours
and other people who eat organ meat and
i'm like well this is a good way to get
it so
so okay so it's still it's still good
it's just not quite as good with yeah
when you a lot of times unless you are
like making your burgers well done some
people will the burger will be like a
medium rare burger and the center of the
burger might have some liver in it
that's like a little less cooked and
then you're probably getting a lot of
good nutrients okay but okay yeah you
can do fresh
you can do lightly cooked you can do
cooked or you can do desiccated okay um
in the pills for meat wise like
i had chicken a day and i was just
thinking you probably were gonna say
that's bad what kind of meat is
the you know i
what is the most healthy meat and what
kind of meats do you eat
so those those those the answer to both
of those questions i think is is the
same answer because i i try and
think about nutrient density quality of
all my foods so um this may come as a
shock to people but i think the
healthiest meat on the planet now is red
meat and we've been told red meat is bad
for us but we need to understand that
that is based on observational studies
and we can talk about why they're
[ __ ] if you want or we can just
accept that there's really no good
interventional evidence to suggest that
red meat is bad for humans as many
people should be if you're concerned
about the quality of the red meat get
something that's grass-fed
grass-finished potentially
regeneratively raised which means
rotational grazing which means that cow
is on a field living pretty darn close
to the way its ancestors and bison have
lived on grasslands for millions and
millions of years so the closest thing
that most people can get to eating an
animal which is having its
species-appropriate diet is a grass-fed
grass-finished cow you can also get a
bison if you can find bison there's a
great ranch in texas where i've gone and
seen bison and they're wild animals and
a cow is related but if an animal is
eating it's really truly
species-appropriate diet from birth to
death that's going to be a healthier
animal for humans and that's why i think
asking questions around what is a
species-appropriate diet for humans is
critical too so those are land animals
so i think they're
more
free from pesticides more free from
toxins now they're not going to be
perfect depending on where the cows are
raised because there's a lot of places
especially in the u.s where there's no
pure grass
but one thing i've talked about in my
social media that confuses people is
pork and chicken is way worse there are
essentially no chickens in the like in
the united states unless it's a backyard
chicken of your friend that is eating
bugs and grubs and chicken scraps and
maybe some meat from their kitchen
all the chickens out there are fed corn
and soy and
if you look at chicken feed so
i'm i have dogs and i want to i'm
building a company that's making a good
dog food that's just meat and organs
that could help me out a lot because i
cook my dog's food and it's a bit of
work
yeah it is a lot of work so we're
working on a company it's coming soon
for a good dog food but one of the
things we're going to do after we make
the dog food is we're going to make
chicken feed because in our research
there it was impossible for us to find
any chicken feeds out there for anyone
in their backyard that didn't have seed
oils so things like corn canola
safflower sunflower soybean especially
so if chickens are fed soybean oil
they're going to hold onto that oil it
gets stuck in their body just like it
gets stuck in us as humans yeah so we
know these seed oils get stuck in us as
humans they get stuck in chickens they
get stuck in pork and that's why i'm not
a huge fan of chicken and pork now
occasionally it's not the end of the
world but i want to give people
what i think is the ideal so that they
can use that as a north star the same
thing is true of pork it's all fed it's
fed grains it's fed soy so
bacon is delicious but
you know i just posted this real on
instagram the death of bacon and people
lose their mind they just get so
triggered like i'm not giving a bacon i
said okay don't give up your bacon i'm
just telling you i don't think it's
healthy for you because it's fed corn
and soy and that bacon fat
is full of accumulated seed oils and i
don't think humans do well when they
have excess amounts of this one
particular fatty acid that's found in
seed oils linoleic acid and we can come
back to that if you want but let me tell
you about fish so
fish is pretty dirty these days even
wild fish and if you look at this
so danica i was really surprised to see
this but a study came out recently it's
an observational study so you can't draw
a causative inference but the
association is strong and it really
it really leads to a compelling
hypothesis or a concern there's a clear
link between fish consumption and
increased rates of melanoma in humans no
way
yeah the researchers were very i think
they were just very confused but it's
not
confusing because fish is pretty
contaminated with heavy metals
polycarbonate biphenyls oh man i had
such i had my mercury level was
extremely severe you know i i mostly ate
fish for a while and you and tony
robbins had like mercury
i mean even joe rogan's talked about
arsenic in his blood from eating
sardines and so
fish is a source of heavy metals it's
also polychlorinated biphenyls and then
you have microplastics now which people
are just starting to talk about in fish
we don't have any good studies in humans
with microplastics but in animal models
microplastics impair fertility they
impair hormones they're they do not look
good for
for
like life on this earth and so
where do you get most of your
microplastics you get them from fish you
can get them from a sea salt but now
there's micro plastic low micro plastic
sea salts are available
but you're getting micro plastics from
eating seafood so
i don't think people understand how
dangerous it is to be a pescetarian
today the intention is really good right
like i'm going to be healthy i'm making
an intentional choice in my diet but
you're only eating
fish and vegetables and fruit whatever
but you're the only source of protein is
the most highly contaminated source of
protein even things like wild salmon
there's plenty of mercury in there i
mean i challenge people to do this like
check your mercury you can even do blood
levels of mercury you don't need to do a
provoked mercury just do a blood level
of mercury eat salmon for three or four
times in a week and get the best wild
alaskan salmon and i guarantee your
mercury will be double what it was at
the beginning of the week and then don't
even check your mercury if you're eating
something like swordfish or oppa or mahi
mahi or tuna there's tons oh i get it i
get it i mean i love swordfish i would
eat that it kind of stays well you can
you know if you cook too much you can
have more i mean i did that and
um i reached out to mark hyman because
it was actually from heavy metal
toxicity that got him into the
functional medicine world and basically
he was like just stop eating fish for
six months have a good day and i was
like okay and but wait
let's just also point out
i i love mark and i i really want to
collaborate with him in the future but
he advocates a pagan diet like he is
advocating
for a pescetarian vegan diet like
let's just point that out there are a
lot of doc i mean like even when you
talk about like i love him and i think
he's brilliant
david sinclair is like
definitely advocating for a more
plant-based diet and no red meat or less
red meat and things like that and
that's why i think that's just
interesting as we as we propose
questions and don't agree on things or
don't have the same idea it's maybe that
they we don't agree it's just works
exploring it's we'll find answers it's
in this it's in the it's in these
questions that will find answers and so
um i think that i think this is an
important um important conversation to
have for that um i'm wondering you know
people worry about uh cholesterol and
things like that and is cholesterol just
[ __ ] i just have this like intuition
that like cholesterol is this old
mechanism of
judging your
health and i because
i i don't know i mean i have really good
high my my good cholesterol is really
high and also my bad cholesterol is
really high and
um i have really really high cholesterol
then um but i just don't know if there's
i don't just i feel like it's kind of
some [ __ ]
the concept of good and bad cholesterol
is total [ __ ] um
and i'll try and explain it this gets a
little technical most people will know
that canonically bad cholesterol is ldl
low density lipoprotein good cholesterol
is hdl high density lipoprotein but it's
much more complicated than that
so we just need to understand that what
we are calling bad cholesterol ldl is
critical for
your health for my health to make
hormones to make all the sex hormones in
our bodies testosterone estrogen
progesterone you need
the cholesterol molecule that is
transported in an ldl
lipoprotein so ldl is a bus it's like a
balloon right it has a single lipid
monolayer it's a bust that moves
cholesterol which is actually a steroid
molecule and triglycerides throughout
your body what do triglycerides do they
form the cell membranes of every cell in
your body
and cholesterol is the building block
for all of your steroid hormones all the
hormones that we need to live the
hormones you need to to
absolutely control
sugar regulation the morale corticoids
the hormones of stress cortisol the
hormones of sexual dimorphism estrogen
testosterone progesterone progesterone
those are all cholesterol-based
molecules so we are calling the bus that
takes cholesterol to the cells
that make those essential hormones bad
cholesterol like wait what no that
doesn't make any sense
there are there are
genetic deficiencies of cholesterol
there's a genetic condition
called smith lemley oppet syndrome where
people don't make
enough cholesterol and these kids are
born with mental delay they're stunted
they have diabetes a lot of them die in
infancy or in childhood and the
treatment for this is basically giving
them as many egg yolks as possible we
just give them as much cholesterol as we
possibly can because they can't make it
so cholesterol the steroid molecule is
essential and that little bus the ldl
particle that we call bad cholesterol to
move that around is essential for human
life
furthermore ldl also participates in the
immune system very few people talk about
this but ldl is an immune particle both
ldl and hdl participate in the immune
system by disrupting quorum sensing
which is how bacteria communicate in
your blood so these particles actually
will will stick onto they will grab onto
the molecules bacteria are using to
communicate and pull them out of the
circulation so they will help with an
infection and there's good evidence from
both humans and animal models that if
you give
someone or an animal more ldl
cholesterol they fight off infections
better and if you pull ldl cholesterol
from an animal or you look at humans who
have low ldl cholesterol they are more
susceptible to infections they get
hospitalized more they get more septic
now
again tell me why this is bad
cholesterol
so i think it's more nuanced than this
and this is where things get a little
complex i won't deny that there is
evidence that ldl can be involved in the
process of atherosclerosis in the
arterial wall
but i do not believe and this is the
important statement i do not believe
there is any evidence to suggest that
ldl initiates that process or is
directly injurious to that arterial wall
because people will say
bad cholesterol causes heart attacks
[ __ ] bad cholesterol doesn't cause
heart attacks bad cholesterol ends up in
the arterial wall possibly there
delivering
building blocks possibly there getting
wrapped into an inflammatory response
but to say that ldl engineers the
arterial wall
is not founded in science so what does
injure the arterial wall what initiates
the process
essentially metabolic dysfunction
insulin resistance which we know delays
wound healing delays turnover of
membranes and inhibits our production of
glutathione the major antioxidant
molecule in the human body so there is
another event before ldl gets wrapped
into the atherosclerotic plaque does
that make sense yeah you did a great job
of explaining it
and i'll just go one step further and
say that if you look at the medical
research
and you take a selection of people and
you just plot
ldl cholesterol across the the y-axis
and heart or ldl cholesterol on the
x-axis and heart disease incidence on
the y-axis you may see a curve that goes
up in a line if you just take a broad
swath of humans right and you say okay
more ldl cholesterol is associated with
more cardiovascular disease but i think
most
physicians and most clinicians and even
most of the lay public are missing the
actual details of that graph which is
the next step of that graph
if you take that and you add one more
variable to that graph and you graph ldl
along the x-axis right and you graph
heart disease incidence on the y-axis
and you split that one line into four
lines and you stratify based on insulin
sensitivity okay this is how diabetic or
pre-diabetic someone is and you can use
any marker you want
fasting insulin hdl is a good metric
right you can use triglycerides hdl
ratio you can use any single metric you
want
and sub stratify that curve that line
and you will see a very different
relationship you will see four lines
that have completely different slopes
and the bottom line will essentially be
a flat line and that is the line of
people who are insulin sensitive that is
the line of people who have a low
fasting insulin yeah that is a line of
people who have a high hdl
that is the line of people who have low
triglycerides who are not diabetic in
any way shape or form and have no
pre-diabetes no metabolic dysfunction
there is no relationship between ldl
cholesterol and heart disease incidents
in people who are insulin sensitive wow
and that is what is being missed by the
medical establishment and
you it sounds like are going to doctors
who are thinking outside the box
when you go to doctors who are regular
doctors who are also intelligent and
well-meaning have you ever had them draw
a fasting insulin
ever i mean i get blood draws and i
usually do it fasted in the morning but
do they do a fasting insulin it's almost
never ever done and that one blood test
would change the face of western
medicine because it's such an easy way
to tell if you are metabolically healthy
aka insulin sensitive or insulin
resistant but a regular quote unquote
doctor right not going to get an insulin
so we're not even understanding yeah the
doctors are not doing anything to
contextualize well how much are they
even doing labs like how much are they
actually even just doing labs like i
mean i what kind of set me on my like
aggressive health journey was um a year
and a half ago having like cycle
irregularity and then i was like i
should probably go to the doctor and i
requested all these labs like i was like
hey these things are going on let's
check my hormones
and i mean i was 39 38 about to be 39
years old and it had really not ever
been requested of me like hey you know
i'm your doctor let's just check these
things that's you have to literally go
out and seek a functional doctor and
usually you don't do that until
something's wrong
there's nothing like nothing in the
medical establishment i feel like it
sets the precedent that we should all
have baseline testing we should start
doing these things regularly at a
certain age like you have to have
something wrong and seek it out and so i
requested labs and then you know the
first time it's you know maybe
seven eight vials and the next time i'm
like let's do more labs let's figure and
now all of a sudden it's 12 12 vials and
you know this one the other day is 16
and you know i mean if you want to get
your food sensitivity test it's 20 vials
and you know it takes a lot of effort to
actually get information for yourself i
think this is a problem with the way
doctors are taught and it's something i
want to be a part of changing i think
that it's not the fault of the
physicians
like i said i think that all the doctors
i've ever met invariably smart
kind want to do good we're just not
taught this
we're not taught to look for the root
cause
we're we're a part of a system that is
based mostly on an insurance model that
limits the amount of time you get to see
a patient to five to seven minutes if
you actually want to be
reimbursed at a reasonable rate you
don't have time to hear a story you
don't have time to know
what your patient is passionate about
what they are in you know what they
really enjoy in their life you don't
have time to understand
why they want to be healthy or what
their disease means to them or what they
think is causing their illness you don't
have time to understand how motivated
they are to change their diet they don't
you don't have time to understand what
they're eating you don't even you know
when i was in
medical school and residency
you know like when i'm
observing people taking histories
just like how's your diet oh it's good
okay
check the box like you don't have time
uh you know i'm in the emergency room at
midnight you know i don't i'm not i mean
this isn't the right setting to
necessarily go into a full dietary
recall but even when i've done
outpatient work there's pressure on you
you don't have time it's not the
system's not built
and i would often try and understand
these things in whatever context i could
but
like
your physician doesn't really like
they're not educated number one to think
about diet do they know about lectins do
they know about oxalates
do they know about like the benefits of
red meat or the benefits of organs are
they going to ask you hey are you eating
liver they might say hey danica you
actually have an mthfr polymorphism
you're not really methylating that well
and your homocysteine is a little high
or you have no general doctors ever are
you sure they have but you know that's
are you getting rolls off the tip of
their tongue
yeah are you eating liver and heart
because you need more riboflavin and
more folate in your diet this almost
seems a little high like hey you're
fasting insulin is a little high
um and just people know i think fasting
insulin should be less than five micro
iu per ml preferably less than three
um but there's oh you're fasting
insulin's about 6.5 hey have you been
like
eating processed sugar or seed oils oh
you don't let me tell you about seed
oils danica like this is not the
conversation that physicians are having
with patients
and i think that's why
we all continue to suffer because we're
not getting to the root causes and
understanding all these things but
that's that's just a circle entire bow
on the ldl
yes the idea of good and bad cholesterol
is [ __ ] it has to be viewed in a
context and that context is your insulin
sensitivity if you are seeing a doctor
and i'm speaking to you and the
listeners and and they tell you your
cholesterol is high and you need a
statin but they haven't drawn a fasting
insulin and they're not looking at your
hdl and your triglycerides or your
hemoglobin a1c and you're fasting
glucose
then i think they're missing the entire
picture they basically have blinders on
and they're looking at one little piece
and that is ldl and so much of western
medicine is myopic like this and
well-known
very intelligent very respected
physicians become myopic like this well
disc you know people in the social media
space like they are very ldl myopic they
just say ldl and or apob if it's high
you need a statin and i say that's just
way oversimplified yeah i'm pretty sure
i feel like it's pretty well known that
statins are kind of [ __ ] in and of
themselves so what if there was like so
to to kind of wrap it up at least like i
could go on and on there's so many
things i did not ask you about but like
as a final point maybe to just sort of
because you made a great point about
cholesterol and fasting insulin level
and metabolic flexibility and just
metabolic health so what is the best way
for someone to be insulin sensitive and
i know there's probably probably a lot
of people listening that don't even know
what that means but you can kind of look
it up and just know that being insulin
sensitive is important um so
what can people do to be more insulin
sensitive and um i'm kind of hoping
you'll maybe add a piece about fasting
in there if that is part of the equation
as i'm curious about that myself it can
be but it doesn't have to be we can talk
about it so
the first step is to know
if you're insulin sensitive or not so
get a fasting insulin because that will
make it concrete for everyone listening
and if you have a doctor
who won't draw a fasting insulin get a
new doctor right it's literally even if
your insurance doesn't cover it it's 35
like i almost want to set up a
non-profit that just pays for people to
get fasting insulin like we could do you
know like
you know ten thousand fasting insulins
would change the landscape of you know
like we'll just pay for everyone to get
free fasting insulin what if someone has
a what if someone has like i have a like
a glucose monitor what if someone has a
glucose monitor is that going to give
you any indication of would you not no
no you need not enough no because you
you can't tell what your fasting insulin
is based on your fasting glucose okay
okay so you've got to get a fasting
insulin so get a fasting insulin step
one if it's less than five
then you're probably doing good i would
prefer to see it less than three minus
two point four do you know what your
fasting insulin is i don't
okay well when you get i'm sure it's
been tested i'll do that we'll do a
whole follow-up and i'll be like here's
my labs
and i want people to understand that i
eat
i eat 200 to 300 grams of carbohydrates
a day from fruit and honey and my
fasting insulin is 2.4 that's a whole
separate rabbit hole we're not going to
go down today but fruit and honey do not
create insulin resistance what does
create insulin resistance
seed oils
corn canola safflower sunflower soybean
grape seed peanuts slip that [ __ ] into
everything too cut exactly cut it out
just cut it out
and process sugar not
fruit
and not honey it's really interesting to
see that there's a real divergence
in the way that quote unquote sugar
whether it's sucrose or glucose or
fructose
act in the human body when they are in a
food matrix
versus when they are stripped out of a
food matrix i don't think many people
would question that coca-cola and
processed sugar is bad for humans
creates fatty liver creates insulin
resistance but fruit and honey don't do
this
for a variety of reasons whether they're
involving nitric oxide derivatives or
other things that have informational
signaling roles in the human body fruit
and honey do not make you insulin
resistant i'm proof of that there's good
evidence for that in the medical
literature so do not fear
fruit and honey as sources of
carbohydrates i think those are the
least toxic plant foods sources of
carbohydrates and they're just delicious
so like you know don't worry they are
delicious
yeah they're amazing but processed sugar
in coca-cola in candy bars in bread in
ketchup in ice cream and seed oils in
so many things in salad dressings in
baked goods
in i mean i was in the grocery store and
i picked up a salmon patty right this is
a salmon burger i used these when i was
a kid i would love these a salmon burger
made from alaskan salmon had soybean oil
in it right so
definitely you know plant-based burgers
plant-based meat have have these seed
oils and here's the real
kicker
that if you look at the guidelines the
united states government guidelines from
2020 to 2025 they recommend
seed oils
they recommend they recommend seed oils
because everyone is still stuck
20 years ago in the sphere of saturated
fat
and they're recommending seed oils
so this is the hard part right the
dietary guidelines contain recommended
seed oils if you go to a cardiologist i
would say that probably seven out of ten
cardiologists will recommend that you
eat seed oils because they lower ldl we
are so myopically focused
on ldl that we have lost the forest for
the trees there's plenty of good
evidence that eating
a seed oil so replacing a saturated fat
which i would say is healthy for humans
like butter
animal fat tallow which is like butter
made from cow fat
replacing those fats with corn canola
safflower sunflower we've done this in
experiments ldl goes down but oxidized
ldl goes up and we know that oxidized
ldl is broken ldl that's ldl that's
already been incorporated into a plaque
and there's another marker that is a
much better predictor of cardiovascular
disease lp little a lipoprotein little a
which is a type of lip of ldl
lipoprotein that one also goes up so i
don't know how any cardiologist can in
good faith recommend a seed oil
that raises oxidized ldl and raises lp
little a it's because we've all got
these blinders on them we're so myopic
and we just focus on lower ldl
we're missing the whole picture
what about like olive oil avocado oil
that kind of stuff right i can see the
tamari like you're just you're so afraid
of what i'm going to say here so
here's what i would say
the reason seed oils are bad
we don't really understand that's not a
seed oil though they're not a seed oil
but they're not a seed oil but but check
this out they but the reason seed oils
are problematic is because they have
linoleic acid so linoleic acid is an 18
carbon omega-6 polyunsaturated fatty
acid
and in the nutrition space a lot of
people will say a calories a calorie and
if you just restrict your calories
you'll lose weight you'll be healthy
that's [ __ ]
calorie quality matters and different
fats have different essentially hormonal
effects in the body it's like if you
give someone estrogen or you give them
testosterone they're going to have
massively different effects in the human
body right if you give someone linoleic
acid and you give someone a saturated 18
carbon fatty acid which is called steric
acid those have completely different
effects in the human body essentially in
the same way you know steroid molecules
testosterone and estrogen are a few
atoms different like there's just a few
bonds different they look exactly the
same
there's a few double bonds different
between linoleic acid and stearic acid
they're both 18 carbon
stearic acid is a saturated fat
associated with fat loss associated with
good healthy metabolism in humans
linoleic acid associated with all sorts
of problems in excess there's a little
bit of linoleic acid in meat and a
little bit of linoleic acid in eggs but
evolutionarily
people like the hadza only get maybe two
percent of their calories from linoleic
acid in the last 100 years our
consumption of linoleic acid has doubled
more than like it's over 150 percent
we're getting 15 percent of our calories
from linoleic acid these days as humans
it just breaks our metabolism so there's
yeah so you're saying that's olive oil
then you're saying olive oil is linoleic
acid no here's what i'm saying oh okay
olive oil is about 15
linoleic acid
right seed oils are between 25 and 65
percent linoleic acid avocado oil is
kind of like
uh olive oil about 15 percent linoleic
acid
tallow butter 2 linoleic acid so i think
that here's what i say to olive oil
why would you use olive oil when you
could use an animal fat when you could
use a butter or when you could use
them i mean because here because we're
assuming that we're not having a salad
in that's what i'm talking about like
because you're poor so you don't really
need olive oil anymore olive oil on your
salad
i was talking to andrew huberman about
this and i said why are you using olive
oil he said because i put it on my salad
and i said
why are you eating a salad
i get it you want a liquid fat here's
the problem with olive oil and avocado
oil
a lot of them are cut with seed oils a
lot of them are rancid and they're just
less stable if you eat more animal fat
you will feel better as a human fat wise
then rank your favorites because i don't
i don't know if i've had tallow actually
it's a raw butter
oh okay it's a raw butter raw butter i
actually got some raw butter from a
company but rob raw dairy is not readily
available it's challenging depending
what state you're in yeah so fair raw
butter is my favorite then tallow tallow
is not butter it's not dairy there's no
casein or whey and tallow no it's it's
basically rendered fat from an animal
from a cow's fat it's like lard but from
a cow and i'm not a huge fan of lard
because that pig is fed corn and soy
remember it's going to have lots of
linoleic acid yes
this is circling back to our discussion
about chickens and about pork right that
the reason i'm not a fan of eating
chickens and pork is because you're
feeding them seed oils and their
linoleic acid levels in the fat go high
so basically i think this is my
this is the paradigm that i think is is
going on here and again this is my
hypothesis we need to test this but i
think there's a lot of good evidence to
suggest this is the case
humans need a very small amount of
linoleic acid like maybe less than one
percent of our calories you couldn't
avoid it it's in everything right it's
in it's in animal fat so you're eating a
ribeye steak that's grass-fed and grass
finish there's a small amount of
linoleic acid but if you cross over a
certain threshold then things start to
get bad in humans like it's a dose
effect of linoleic acid essentially
crosses over and you get problems when
you have too much linoleic acid what's
too much linoleic acid we don't really
know but i think anything above two to
three percent of your calories from
linoleic acid is a problem for a lot of
humans now
again this is all framed in the
discussion of what is your fasting
insulin the reason i want people to
avoid seed oils is because i want them
to be metabolically healthy if you are
using olive oil
on a
salad
uh
of spinach yeah with spinach kale you're
killing me i don't eat kale anymore
david asprey got me to get off gail and
i didn't really love kale anyway um but
i do i do spinach and arugula
i think you're gonna be better without
the spinach
especially because of the oxalates so if
you're if you're eating olive oil in
your salad and your fasting insulin is
three whatever it's fine eat olive oil
could you be better possibly you know
like you can't really put tallow on a
salad so you know i would say like try
and experiment without the salad without
the olive oil maybe you'd feel better
overall so it's there is something there
so that's why i'm not a fan of olive and
avocado oils it's like it's just it's
kind of like second-class citizens why
would you not eat an animal fat i think
that as humans
so
one of the things we actually make it
hard in soil is tallow in a pill it's
called fire starter and the stuff we
hear about this i mean you can get
tallow in a jar or you can get it in a
pill from us people have like incredible
and exercise performance energy and
weight loss because people don't get
enough animal fat women especially but
men too we're afraid of animal fat so
when we put tallow when we put high
stearic acid tallow in a pill
people can get more animal fat and they
feel better this is what i think that's
why i some people not eat olive oil eat
more animal fat like and maybe you're
getting a ton of animal fat because
you're getting a really fatty ribeye or
you're eating a lot of butter on your
steak or your butter on something else
and you're getting a lot of animal fat i
think most people don't get enough
stearic acid and other fatty acids
they're in animal fat is the stearic
acid why you add
butter to meat because that's something
it looks like you do at every meal it's
like with your meat there's butter i
just like the fat so
i want
a lot of the ground beef i get here says
it's 80 20 but then when i cook it it's
probably more like 90 10 or it's just
too lean
you know i want more fat i had a
tomahawk this morning
i'm trying to get this thing going
called tomahawk tuesday all right so
instead of let's do it instead of tacos
i mean i had a tomahawk this morning and
that tomahawk has a huge thing of fat
like i'm not going to put butter on a
tomahawk or if i have a ribeye that's
really marbled it's a really nice
grass-fed steak that has marbling a lot
of them don't then i'm not going to put
butter on it but i just i can kind of
have this intuitive since like i want my
meat to be fatty and so i'll add butter
to it but you know the fat
on a ribeye that's going to have plenty
of stearic acid but citric acid is an
incredible saturated fat it's so healthy
for humans
i mean like i said we can go on i'll
just say this real quickly that there
are fats in animal fat that are
associated with
improvements in dementia and cognitive
decline in humans they're called odd
chain fatty acids there's like all these
nutrients in animal fat that we've never
been told about we're just told to fear
saturated fat and it's probably
eating more animal fat is probably the
difference between
where someone is and just like the next
level are totally thriving in a much
bigger way in their life because we just
fear it and people don't know like
they're not gonna put butter on their
steak they think that's causing heart
disease when it's not it's just making
you more vital and you know virile and
happy and your body craves that stuff
those nutrients are critical for humans
and if we replace it all with olive oil
then we're doing ourselves a disservice
i see okay then let me ask another
little question here so
total protein amount like wait we didn't
finish the loop on fasting you said
fasting is not that important i wasn't
sure if that was part of like metabolic
health or not um but is there a certain
just general recommended amount of sort
of at least intermittent fasting from
last bite of dinner until the first bite
at breakfast yes
um i think andrew and i might disagree
on this a little bit i think there's too
much emphasis on fasting
in the mainstream medical community i
think fasting is a powerful
quote-unquote drug that is often
overused
so what i've seen often is people will
say if a little bit of fasting is good
then a lot is better and they'll do one
meal a day and i've worked with people
whose testosterone these are men goes
from 900 to 300 when they go to one meal
a day so clearly eating one meal a day
is not good for your sex hormones you
don't want a testosterone to 300 you can
over fast
and so i think that you don't want your
last meal of the day to interrupt your
sleep so i think that the best metric
that i use is i want to finish my last
bite of food
two and a half to three hours before my
head hits the pillow right
you know but i go to sleep early because
i get up early to go surf so if i'm
going to sleep at nine o'clock that
means i have to finish eating by six
right or if i'm going to sleep at 8 30
because i'm getting up at five o'clock
to go surfing i have to finish eating by
5 30. so that's a lot earlier than a lot
of people do
right but if you're going to sleep at 11
o'clock and your circadian rhythm is in
you know is in check and you want to
have dinner at seven that's fine just
finish by 8 pm or whatever and then
and so and then i actually you know i
think that for me it ends up being about
a 14-hour fast i would say overnight
maybe 13 hour fast because i have my
first bite of food before i go surfing
in the morning i actually just have a
couple of tablespoons of honey
around 6 a.m and then i go surf and then
i have my last bite of food usually
around 4 30 or 5 o'clock maybe 5 30 i
have dinner so i'm eating dinner a
little early because sometimes i go to
sleep real early so it just depends
where you want to be but i think what i
would say to people is intermittent
fasting can easily be overused and i
think that you don't have to fast
to be metabolically healthy like i said
i just got my blood work and i am you
know my fasting insulin was 2.4
and some nights i have a 12 hour fasting
window i'm not doing 16 8 anymore i
think that's too much to put it into an
eight hour window for your food
is i think too much for a lot of people
there's actually evidence from some
studies that
when they look put people on a 16-8
fasting the testosterone declined over
time in men
so the sex hormones did suffer when they
just tried to compress it below eight so
i think for a lot of people 10 to 11 for
an eating window is is ideal definitely
you shouldn't be eating and then going
to sleep right that's i think the major
takeaway there but i think fasting gets
overused a lot for some people it's easy
if somebody's out there listening to
this and they're
you know
very overweight great incorporate
fasting but for a lot of us for you for
me like i'm at my goal weight i don't
want to lose muscle like i don't fast
right now because i'm not trying to over
stress my system and i see that i have a
stress bucket you know like
if i'm doing work or i'm working hard
like i'm not gonna fast cause that's
just extra stress on my body it's a
stressor so i see a lot of people
especially women who over fast their
periods become irregular you know the
libido drops and they're just like like
you're already at your goal body weight
why are you fasting well because i heard
xyz person say i need to do this for
longevity like [ __ ] you don't need
to do that for longevity you just need
to be insulin sensitive for longevity
and we're just pushing ourselves way too
far into the stress realm because it is
stressful yep yep okay uh let's wrap it
up with calories then like so you know
is it is there a certain i mean you know
when you eat you you know it looks like
you i think you eat like a pound of meat
and then there's sometimes some butter
on it and there's like half of a papaya
and there's like a quarter of a
pineapple and there's a tall glass of
kefir
there's probably a tablespoon or two of
honey going down
like
you're touching on something that like
at least every girl definitely thinks
about his calories so how do we throw
the [ __ ] flag on calories and what's
the truth what is your what do you go by
yeah this is a great question thank you
so
there is no discussion of calories
without a discussion of food quality
and this to me is
the biggest injustice being done in the
weight loss realm people will say
calories in calories out you know it's
the most oversimplified equation in the
world like the quality of your calories
in affects your calories out your basal
metabolic rate is affected by what you
put in your body we know this like
weight loss
doesn't happen in the gym it's good to
go to the gym or to go outside and hike
and be active we need bdnf brain derived
neurotrophic factor in our brains you
need that you need to be social you need
to move
but that's not where you lose the weight
long-term you lose the weight by getting
healthy
metabolically healthy muscle that is
insulin sensitive and that is where we
get this basal metabolic rate so
people who are lean are lean because
they have a high basal metabolic rate
and that is just burning it's just like
a like a wood burning stove that's
always stoked like as i'm here just
talking to you my body has a high basal
metabolic rate because my muscles are
insulin sensitive and my body is just
burning calories just turning it over
because my thyroid works right and you
can check this on your labs with a free
t3 and a free t4 i don't eat goitrogens
i don't need isothiocyanates hopefully
there's not too many oxalates stuck in
my thyroid so i think a lot of women
have thyroid issues probably due to
autoimmune stuff maybe due to diet but
then also we know that these
polyunsaturated fatty acids these seed
oils can affect our metabolism
negatively and can totally change the
way that we have satiety and hunger and
affect our base of metabolic rate
negatively so
somebody could say to you calories in
calories out danica just restrict your
calories and that'll work in the short
term but that's akin to being in calorie
prison as i call it and nobody wants to
be in prison your body is going to break
out of that your mind is going to break
out of that in a big way and that big
way is going to be cookies and donuts
and fudge creamsicles and you know
molten lava cake i guarantee you like
you're going to break out of calorie
prison eventually so how do you lose
weight sustainably you create high food
quality you create a state of metabolic
health and so i don't really think about
calories you know i did a podcast with
derek from more plates more dates and we
did back of the envelope calculations
i'm 5
10
165 pounds and i probably eat
3 500 calories a day
um it's a lot of calories for somebody
you know and granted people would say
like oh you're surfing yes i surf two
hours every morning
um it's effort but it's not that much
ever but that's a lot of days that's all
i do is surf all i do is serve two hours
but um you know i don't like i'm not in
the gym six hours a day doing a
bajillion workouts i don't really lift
weights that much i do sometimes but if
i've served for two to three hours i'm
good for the day i might do some
mobility i'll do a couple of pull-ups
maybe but i'm not doing crazy workouts
and i think that this works because
my basal metabolic rate is high because
i'm eating good foods so i think that it
starts with
the food quality and so i think we've
got it all backwards weight watchers
this yo-yo dieting over-exercising which
is going to impair your thyroid food in
a package in the frozen section but it
at least hits a number and [ __ ]
[ __ ] if it fits your macros counting
calories no
start with food quality and eat to
satiety that's what i say to people
they're just like what and especially
with women and this is i want to figure
out maybe you can help me with this how
to how to really communicate this well
to women i think that if women
understood that they could eat two
satiety you don't have to stuff yourself
but you can eat as much as you want if
you are eating good quality foods
i mean i think the problem is is like
what i would think for myself is it's
like if it took me as much protein
as
it i think it would to actually be
have satiety it feels like i'd probably
consume
at least 50 grams of protein
you know and i think that the narrative
is that that's way too much protein you
shouldn't be having that much protein
out of sitting and you know like i kind
of go around 30-ish grams and i need
other things like 30 grams of protein is
not going to cut it for me yeah why
don't you just eat 50 grams sounds great
i mean with some more fat with some fat
yeah
i'm really happy i'm well because i'm
going to try that tonight okay i'll let
you know why don't you eat 70 grams of
protein in a meal with some fat like
right so here's the other thing is that
people this is important a lot of people
will say to me i can't eat that much
meat
and i'm saying well that's because
you're filling your plate with like a
bunch of [ __ ] salad like
you know which isn't really it makes you
full temporarily but then it's not
giving you the nutrients from the meat
and granted the vegetables have some
nutrients but they're not as
bio-available as we talked about
anti-nutrients other problems people say
i can't eat that much meat that's
because you're eating a big thing of
bread you know get out of here with that
so like this is the thing and then the
other thing that i hear a lot especially
from women
is that they don't digest meat well
and i think okay this is also because
you're eating vegetables because we know
there are digestive enzyme inhibitors
in plants this is one of the ways plant
defend themselves
is with digestive enzyme inhibitors so i
say to women okay number one you're
probably zinc deficient because you
don't eat enough red meat and you're
only eating fish and you're only eating
chicken because that's what skinny girls
eat right so you're probably zinc
deficient which means you can't make
hydrochloric acid in your stomach which
means the meat isn't going to digest
well the way you fix that is by
gradually increasing your meat and
you're probably eating your meat with
things that inhibit your digestive
enzymes if you ate a big thing of baking
soda with your meal your food isn't
going to digest well because baking soda
is alkaline it's going to completely
destroy the acid in your stomach so
you're not going to have any acid in
your stomach to digest your meal well
you never do that that's the worst idea
ever but that's essentially what you're
doing
when you eat some of these plant foods
with digestive enzyme inhibitors things
like tannins trypsin inhibitors all
these these are in things like nuts and
grains and seeds and some leaves
digestive enzyme inhibitors are in there
they're meant to prevent digestion of
the plants
in your gut so if you have trouble
digesting meat try eating the meat
without eating vegetables you can eat
the meat with fruit you can eat the meat
with honey or butter but i think
gradually over time it will start to
digest better because you're not
inhibiting the digestion but yeah people
say like i can't eat 50 grams of protein
in the meal which is about half a pound
of meat which is reasonable
a good start for most women to do 50
grams in a meal would be great eat that
two or three times a day and you're
gonna be
i think you're gonna see very positive
changes in your body but what woman gets
150 grams of protein a day very few yeah
it's tough to get it's only tough to get
you eat a lot of meat it's only tough to
get if you're eating a lot of salad and
pasta and bread
and hummus and chickpeas and all that
stuff that's true that's true that's
true that's true
all right okay well then okay so i'm
gonna have dinner tonight what should i
have and should i include fruit in that
dinner i'm confused so i can imagine in
the morning maybe it's a little bit
better because you'll use it and there's
a disposal for the
for the sugar
i'm not worried about the fruit in the
evening you can do it like really yeah
your body i already can use it like
remember that like carbohydrates are
kind of a signal of abundance for your
body so i think it's okay to signal your
body twice a day that you have abundance
that you are in a tribe that's in a
fertile area that has fruit on the trees
you know like it's okay to give your
body a signal of abundance and it's
important to realize that sometimes
fasting is not sometimes fasting is the
opposite signal low carb is the opposite
signal you know eating plant-based is
the opposite signal you're giving your
body a signal of scarcity and so your
body goes whoa
you're not gonna have periods because
this is not a time to get pregnant girl
or a guy you know you're not gonna make
you're not gonna have a healthy sperm
count because there's nothing on the
trees and there's no good animals around
here and it's clearly not summer there's
no fruit around to eat so this is not a
good time to make babies like screw that
like we're not doing that stuff right
now we're just trying to get through
winter you're either
you're either giving your body a signal
that it's like abundant
or it's winter right it's and just i
think it's okay to give your body a
signal it's it's summer we evolved at
the equator like it's okay to give your
body a signal of abundance and then what
follows is good skin good sleep libido
energy mental clarity this is the idea
right this is what i hope people will
experience but i want them to test it
for themselves so i think you can give
yourself
fruit at dinner and experiment with how
much feels good for you in terms of your
satiety and how the digestion is i've
had people ask isn't fruit going to
inhibit digestion no it's not it's not
going to change the ph of your stomach
your body can definitely handle fruit or
honey and meat together it works out
just fine so right now in costa rica i
like papaya and pineapple and mango you
probably don't have those fruits in new
york so if you want to have like some
grapes or an avocado which is a fruit
right
or some grapes with dinner or some honey
with your steak and butter so i would
say for dinner get a good rib eye steak
put some good salt on it preferably a
sea salt no pepper no pepper on your
steak
no pepper on your steak and then put
some butter but if it's a fatty ribey
you won't even need butter if you want
to change your world
take a little honey put it on the side
of your plate and put that steak in
honey
sweet and salty baby yes yeah so get
some honey with your steak have some
fruit on the side have some grapes
i'm trying to think what else might be
in season have some bananas strawberries
it's berries have some berries
blueberries grapes maybe some watermelon
yeah and there's your dinner okay yeah
well thank you i think you've just
rocked my world and probably the best
way possible i mean that's the only
point of this conversation is that it's
about progressing and um making better
choices so i'll just close with this i
want to bring it first of all with the
hazard because i want to say this one
thing so when i'm with the hadza
you ask them what is the best day of
your life right and remember this is my
hope for a time machine this is where
humans have come from and their answer
is unequivocal they've given it to other
people you see videos on youtube people
who visited podzo they say the same
thing to us as they did to them it's the
day i hunt and kill the biggest animal
and i share it with the tribe and we
dance and we sing right what is your
favorite food it's the biggest animal
it's an impala you know you ask a woman
what makes a good husband he's a good
hunter okay
you know like you ask men what do they
dream about we dream about hunting so
like this is what i want people to
understand that if you go back in time
we don't know what we find but i think
that the best version the most
appropriate the most accurate facsimile
we have
shows humans
crafting a whole life
around hunting and animals okay they
craft around hunting and animals and
fruit and honey those are the things
they crave they don't celebrate
vegetables they don't celebrate leaves
they don't seek out bitter foods they
will eat those things if they are
starving but only in that situation so
that i think is a really cool
framework to think about this like okay
that made sense to me that's why i went
to visit them because i wanted to see
how humans really
wanted to get food it makes sense
intuitively if you and i are in the
tribe in the forest
we're not going to be looking for bitter
leaves we're going to be trying to hunt
an animal if we see a ripe fruit we're
going to pick it if we see a beehive
we're going to get honey that's what
we're going to do if we starve we might
eat some like roots or some seeds but
most of the time if we can kill an
animal
that's what's for dinner and maybe a
little fruit maybe a little honey it's
like it's so intuitive for humans but
we've been sort of programmed out of it
well well said and i thank you for
bringing that back around because
foundationally i know that's what kind
of sets you on this path so
um i
very much appreciate all of your sharing
and um thank you for all this incredible
information i'm gonna have to listen to
it again for all the details but i know
now what i'm having for dinner you gotta
you gotta let me know you gotta send me
an email let me know how it goes because
i wanna hear this dinner okay
thank you for having me on i appreciate
it thank you so much
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button